the Joe Rogan experience how do we get
going down the path of death I mean
arrows right a werewolf go to my
Instagram John Dudley is riding the
werewolf we were trying to figure out
well the wearables Patrick Magee made
that werewolf and it comes in two paid
pieces you slide out and well Patrick
McGee has a new movie out I should pump
his new movie out if you're into there
it is oh my god it's a lair it's got
5,000 likes already I put them two
minutes ago
that's an awesome picture but uh Pat
McGee the guy who made that just made a
movie a Bigfoot movie it's called a
primal scream I think isn't what it's
called it just came out
is it a legit one or like a horror movie
oh yeah it's a monster okay killing
people I'll watch that Jack and people
in the woods I'll watch that yeah I got
good reviews I hope it's good I love
them I love me a good Bigfoot movie and
there's not a whole lot of them I think
we would just saw a Bigfoot a long time
ago there yeah for sure
I think but but what would you do if you
actually ran across one double lung
would you potat to take the penalty
double lung prove a point
no I would hope I'd have my camera on me
but then people would call me a [ __ ]
liar that would be a bummer
if you really saw a Bigfoot you're like
god damn and he's real never everyone's
gonna think I'm crazy because everybody
that I know that believes in Bigfoot I'm
all-in aren't ya even if you got a
picture yeah then you're gonna then all
the good faith that you built up by
being honest all these years [ __ ] that
guy he's full of [ __ ] he faked a Bigfoot
sighting man yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't
shoot it definitely not but I think if
it was real I really do believe that if
it was real there's a this is the the
trailer for OMA C and Pat McGee did this
with all special effects like suits and
[ __ ] and and actual makeup and
prosthetics and all the stuff that they
used in the old movies like he doesn't
believe in that CGI [ __ ]
think he's got a point at CGI [ __ ] it's
just - it takes away it does I mean you
look back at some of the movies that
scared the you know scared the hell out
of you and your kid and you watch them
now and you're like what man did they it
just seems so much more real but if you
watch something to where you know it's
fake it's you almost can't picture the
fact that it's flesh-and-blood right and
you need you don't feel it like there's
some of those transformer type movies
they're smashing buildings you like I
know this isn't happening just you don't
feel it it doesn't feel like a real
explosion doesn't feel like a real robot
just feels like horseshit
[Applause]